prenaient directement contact avec un groupe classifié comme néofasciste
et des extrémistes islamistes
en envoyant dans leur boîte de réception sur Facebook des messages disant :
« Hé ! J'ai vu où tu allais. Je suis passé par là.
Si tu veux parler, je suis là. »
Nous nous attendions à des menaces de mort avec ces interactions.
C'est alarmant qu'un ancien néo-nazi vous demande comment ça va.
Nous avons découvert qu'environ 60%
des personnes contactées répondaient
et, parmi elles, environ 60% avaient une discussion pérenne,
elles avaient des conversations
avec des gens difficiles à atteindre quant à ce qu'ils traversaient,
plantant des doutes
et leur offrant des alternatives pour parler de ces sujets
et c'est très important.
Ce que nous essayons de faire,
c'est de rassembler des gens de secteurs invraisemblables.
Nous avons de super activistes à travers le monde
mais souvent, leurs messages ne sont pas stratégiques
ou n'atteignent pas les publics cibles.
Nous travaillons avec ces réseaux d'anciens extrémistes,
des réseaux de jeunes gens dans divers endroits du monde.
Nous travaillons avec eux pour rassemble les technophiles,
des artistes, des créatifs, des experts du marketing
afin de contester de façon plus robuste l'extrémisme
en travaillant ensemble.
Je dirais que si vous êtes dans le public
et que vous êtes graphiste,
poète, expert en marketing,
un attaché de presse,
comédien --
vous pensez peut-être que ce n'est pas votre secteur
mais les compétences que vous avez
pourraient être ce qu'il nous faut
pour aider à contrer efficacement l'extrémisme.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)